hello my name is ryan bailey
and i'm pleased to be presenting to you
today some recent work from
our group in developing droplet
microfluidic tools for uses in high
throughput biotechnology
i'd like to thank the organizers of
imitation i'm at the university of
michigan in the department of chemistry
and affiliate in the
department of biomedical engineering um
so while we're really developing
kind of core tools that can be applied
to many applications in high throughput
biotechnology
what's motivated my group are actually
applications
in high throughput and low input
epigenomic studies so i'll provide
a small amount of context as to why
we've been trying
why we want to develop these types of
tools which i hope
um uh demonstrates the utility
uh that these can be used of course in
many other applications as well so i
just want to point out that this work is
being done with a team at my lab as well
as
several people in tomas or dogs group at
the mayo clinic
so it's a little way of motivation
chromatin is organized
with these nucleosomes being the most
basic unit so we often think about dna
there's a double helix or as a
chromosome
but in between there are all these
hierarchical structures
of chromatin structure and again the
core use this nucleosome
which is a protein complex these are
histone proteins which have these small
polypeptide tails
in addition to modifications to dna
which can change the spacing or
compaction of chromatin
these modifications to these polypeptide
tails is also
very important uh and these work
together
uh with readers and writers in the cells
as well as transition factors to
dynamically control
uh gene regulations turns protein
expression on and off effectively
now there are many needs to develop i
would say are clinically applicable
precision epigenetic methods so i think
it comes as no surprise to most in the
audience that epigenetic signatures are
dynamic epigenetic regulation has
profound roles in development but it
also
underscores many other diseases
including cancer and others
importantly there's a growing pipeline
of pharmaceuticals with epigenetic
targeting modes of action so what's
really needed are these
essentially companion diagnostic assays
but in the epigenetic space as opposed
to
the genetic or the protein biomarker
space
so there's a real need for this so it's
really neat to understand
functional consequences of gene specific
and genome-wide epigenomic lesions
and we think that this is going to be
important in a new wave of personalized
medicine
and to accomplish this we really need
fundamentally new measurement tools
uh there are pretty good tools that are
used in the academic and
medical research labs but these really
are do not um
have this feel ability and throughput
needed to robustly establish clinical
significance by looking at large
um patient cohorts and things of that
sort
there are several different classes of
genetic assays um you have potential for
translational significance many of the
tools we're developing can be applied to
many of these
um one that we're not focusing on in
particular is looking at dna and rna
modification so things like methylation
and hydroxylation
of cytosine are handled right now pretty
quite well by bisulfite sequencing
there are assays that are general probes
of chromatin condensation
and that includes things like m a seek
which i'll talk a little bit about later
dna seek and attack seek in particular
which is
been used quite a bit recently and then
finally there are these antibody based
recognition
uh assays where you're looking at
specific histone marks and the
association of those marks with
particular genes
and the most common version of this is
chrome
neutral precipitation or chip seek for
short
and that's what we've really been
focused on for a long-term goal
um and really it's because from a kind
of engineering microfluidic standpoint
it's the
um it's the assay that has the most
individual steps and it's
uh theoretically that would be the
hardest
to automate yet have the largest impact
if we were
able to automate this in a completely
microfluidic
format want to go over quickly what the
cheap chip seek workflow is in bulk and
kind of what other results look like
kind of against framing framing this
talk a little bit
so you typically start with a cell
sample this could be a culture cell
sample a patient sample something like
that
you may want to cross-link if you're
looking at say weak binders like
transcription vectors and their
interaction with dna
um but that's not always necessary what
is necessary is you always need to lyse
the cell and digest the chromatin so
we're going to try to cut it down to
these mononucleosomes the smallest
fundamental unit of chromatin structure
if you didn't throw in magnetic beats
that's antibody on them these antibodies
are
have specificity for particular
modifications on the peptide tails
shown here these red triangles then you
can use the magnetic nature of these to
pull out just the mononucleosomes that
have histones having
a certain mark you can release that dna
purify it
and take it downstream with something
like sequencing um and here's an example
on the right from
our collaborators at mayo clinic just
showing uh
some chip seek data on a
gastrointestinal
thermal tumor a gift just sample uh and
here's a look
at three different marks of promoting
mark h3 k4 trimethyl
and two different repressing marks and
really just the only thing that's
important to see is we see these very
defined peaks for these promoting marks
and kind of orthogonal islands uh or or
lack of marks uh lack of reads
in regions where overlapping between
promoting and repressing marks
so that's kind of the long-term
objective
so what are the impediments to that uh
to the clinical implementation of that
general scheme i showed you well while
these methods are very well established
they're laborious and highly influenced
by
the level of user expertise even in an
academic lab in my lab it can take
someone
a couple years how to how to really
robustly run
these chip seek experiments you should
the ip pull down
uh this makes them very much not
amenable for large-scale studies or
discovery of
biomarkers epigenetic biomarkers also
not suitable for use in central
laboratory settings just requires too
much technician time
another potential limitation is that
they have relatively large input
requirements because of the many steps
involved
this means you cannot apply these
techniques easily to
sample limited types of samples such as
circulating tumor cells tumor biopsies
or more
specifically laser capture micro
dissection to look at heterogeneity
or cancer stem cells so it's really an
opportunity and a need to
automate to go to lower inputs and much
more high throughput for these assays so
the idea would be that
rather than a four plus day assay that
requires billions
ten millions of cells you're looking at
one mark at a time it's very user
independent
the idea would be using a microfluidic
device to push this process down to
hours
taking advantage of enhanced mixing and
diffusional transport that happens on
these short
micro micrometer link scales push this
down to hundreds or thousands of cells
many single cells eventually make this
parallel so we can look at multiple
marks or multiple transcription factors
simultaneously
really a huge benefit would come from
being able to automate this
um using using microfluidic tools
so we're not the first ones to to think
about automating
or using microfluidics and applied to
chip these are severed several different
notable examples from literature
but all of them really still have some
limitations
the nice one to point out because i i
think informs why we're trying to use
the approach that we are
well one is that while microfluidics are
fantastic they go into small volumes
they end up having gigantic surface to
volume ratios
and we can think about any surface at a
microfluidic device potentially
as a place where we could lose sample
sample could stick
onto the walls of the plastic or glass
that
the chip is made out of many of them
often have very complicated valve
controls you have to be opening and
closing different bells to control
what's added or taken out of the sample
this requires skilled operation
there's often sample loss between steps
so many of these involve like say
filling of loops and things like that
and if you want to add reagent to a loop
you have to push out a little bit of
what was already in there so that gives
you sample loss
other these approaches are very much
optimized for limited or fixed volume
samples
and that means if you have a sample
that's larger or smaller than what you
have optimized your device for you to
kind of go back to the drawing board and
change geometries or antibody loading or
things things of that sort
finally none of these approaches have
been able to fully integrate
all steps you can take the cellular
input and from that cell
input um prepare the nucleosomes on chip
into the immunocapsular chip usually
they'll start with say
nucleosomes that have already been made
and our goal is to
take cells for inputs and eventually
have sequencing libraries on the back
side that we're not we're not quite
there so i'm not going to be able to
tell you about that part today
and then finally they have that
side-by-side validated with conventional
chip and this is very important in a
translational
um from a translational perspective
because clinicians are not going to
believe
um or readily believe the results from a
microfluidic device
they cannot be compared side by side
with bulk scale preparation
so one of the approaches that we've
taken is to be able to develop devices
that can be upscaled we can run them for
longer periods of time
and actually accommodate the large
sample input that's typically used in a
bulk chip experiment so we can do just
robust side by side comparisons
so our approach has been a little
different than the others i talked about
before is to use
droplet microfluidics and these are
these are segmented liquid liquid flows
it's we would in which we have a
continuous oil phase this is often a
fluorinated oil
think about it like a teflon that
actually makes it so the side walls of
the channels
aren't sticky which is important we
don't want to lose material by the side
walls
but we can inject a aqueous liquid into
this and it will um
branch off and actually form a small
droplet break off into
the flow so we make these continuous
flow droplets so as i mentioned there's
this really nice
advantage because we have limited
non-specific binding also each one of
these
um is essentially its own little
reaction chamber which means we have
very limited
uh cross contamination from droplet to
droplet or potentially
sample the sample we don't require
additional
mixing elements in these types of
devices because there's this natural
convective flow inside of droplets that
leads to
a very nice mixing internally within the
droplets
so that's an advantage and also as i
mentioned before these have
indeterminate operation
i can run this device for a short period
of time and make just a few droplets
where i can run it for
a longer period of time and make you
know thousands of droplets even just in
a just in a couple seconds
that allows us to think about how we can
scale this to accommodate different
types of
sample input so here's kind of our
strategy if you will to move chip to a
chip so i've kind of shown again the
different steps involved with bulk chip
from taking the cells to isolating
nuclear chromatin
digesting the chromatin followed by the
immune precipitation
and dna purification so you've actually
broken this into eventually three
modules but the two that we've really
focused on
uh first and that is a cell
encapsulation
uh and we're going to do this uh with
the presence of detergent and
micrococconuclease just to start that
cell lysis digestion immediately
this incubation of our cells for fixed
periods of time for defined periods of
time
and then at the end we can actually add
in our edta buffer which chelates the
calcium out of this enzyme we're going
to use and it quenches the reaction and
at the same time we can add in magnetic
beads if we'd like for the downstream
amino capture process
we then have developed a few different
approaches towards magnetic
watching flushing and i'll come back to
this but we use what we
called fondly a car wash device and i'll
talk about what this is
to do uh bead washing um as well
and then finally what we haven't brought
on ship is this dna purification
and downstream analysis that's there's
precedent for doing these things
um on device as well
so as i mentioned before we're going to
be using an enzyme to
digest our chromatin in large academic
labs or research labs people typically
use
um or can often use sonicators which are
actually very expensive
and difficult to operate very sample
size dependent
one of the advantages of using this
micrococc
in the nucleus or eminace is that it's
very gentle it doesn't degrade any
proteins
doesn't require any flexible uh or uh
specialized equipment flexible reaction
volume we can incubate control
incubation time very precisely in
microfluidic devices so this
is an immune nucleus that will basically
just chew up any dna
until it gets to a nucleosome at which
point uh you can't can't eat anymore
so this is the the steps here we're
gonna combine ourselves with our
detergent and our
um uh our digestion buffer make droplets
we can incubate them
in these delay channels then we can
quench the reaction
so here's an example of what one of
these devices looks like
again up front we have where we make the
droplet formation
in this region here these are where we
do the incubation and it's really
important to point out that
when we make these microfluidic devices
which is actually quite simple
we can change the number of these delay
channels we have
so i'll show you some data where we just
actually stop after one row of these
delay channels for a very short
incubation time although that's
something we can control very nicely
very easily on chip and finally this
injection down here this quenching
buffer and droplet collection before
moving on to the next module
so here's just a kind of side on 3d
rendering of this and i wanted to show a
few videos
so you can get a uh appreciation for
what these look like in action
here at the droplet formation port we
have our cells come in you can see these
little cells floating beyond the channel
and this other channel that's merging
with it's an aqueous buffer that has the
detergent
the micrococconuclease uh this will then
form
uh droplets and many of these droplets
are actually empty
uh but if they have a cell just
statistically based upon poisson
statistics still only have a single cell
so we're effectively doing single cell
processing but we're just doing it on
you know many thousands of cells
simultaneously but it's important that
we're doing single cell processing
uh here's the beginning of this delay
channel uh so we made the leg chain a
little thicker so we can
are deeper so we can accommodate more
droplets but here you see the droplets
coming in
here's a drop of cell limit entering the
delay channel
um at the end of the delayed channel
again we can have as many as we want we
see the droplets are still intact
they just move through these delay
structures to get a
nice homogeneous incubation time and
then finally we're able to inject
um this edta containing buffer which
chelates the calcium and stops the
enzymatic digestion
at the end so here's a
picture of the microfluidic device
filled the food dye so it's easy to see
you can see it's about five centimeters
by say three centimeters in size so
quite small quite compact
um and here's the results if we do this
microcopial nucleus digestion using just
one row of delay channels so we know
that we're doing a very short incubation
here only about 45 seconds
but what we see are just after 45
seconds of incubation
we can already clearly see
mononucleosomes dining fluid zones try
nucleosomes and larger
relatively undigested peaks of chromatin
but again we can control the number of
channels that we have delay channels to
optimize our incubation time and that's
shown here
these are uh these are electrophoretic
collector ferrograms
looking at samples from 45 seconds up to
305 seconds
we can see this nice large peak of
modern nucleosomes really in all the
samples
but at 45 seconds we still have some dye
and trinucleosomes
they really go away with a longer
incubation period
um this is actually slight over
digestion of the dna which is actually
really nice for the nucleosome
positioning acids
that i'm going to talk about later
showing quantitatively here
we see that as we go from 45 even just
up to 90 seconds of incubation we
already have
the only order of 80 percent
mononucleosomes which is again what we
what we desire for these nucleosome
positioning assays
and if anything we see that our on chip
uh here in red performs
uh you know in some cases even better or
she's using the on-chip on black
performs even better than the off-chip
uh dungeons to the tube so really nice
processing
of this chromatin to mononucleosomes
from wholesale inputs
um using this device also since we're
really processing
these cells one at a time it doesn't
matter how many we process
so we can see as we go from 125 000
cells down to just
2500 cells that we have essentially
equivalent mononuclease on the yield
so again that's the benefit of doing
essentially you know
many um you know one after the other
single cell processes um and we can go
lower but actually the
we don't get enough signal out of our
electro ferrograms to to do this this is
actually one of the limitations as you
start to go to single cell onyxes you
don't have
some of the same characterization
methods available that looks like this
method would be amenable to single cell
processing
and again also since we see consistent
results this allows us to upscale we can
run this and we can look at 10 million
cells
just by running this device for a longer
period of time which we think is
going to be important uh so here's some
uh m
a seek data that i'm going to show i
know there's a lot of data up here on
the slide
we're going to focus on uh four g
regions
uh the first two i want to focus on here
on the left eif1
and uh fumarate hydrocase these are both
genes that are consistently
uh active in the jerk cat cells we're
working with
so we see here flanking the
transcription sites these genes are
actively poised for expression
under active regulation so we see these
nuclear zone free regions
in all the samples whether they're on
chip or off chip
whether they're free which means we've
made the sequencing libraries without
pcr or reviews pcr to make libraries we
see
consistent nucleosome free regions
flanking
the transcription start site which is
what you'd expect because you need to
have a free region
for the transcription machinery to come
down and recognize that this is where
you're supposed to start
um transcribing and binding and
processing
in contrast when you look at these two
other genes uh g-fat
and tyrosine hydroxylase these are both
uh developmentally re
uh pressed in the t cells you have these
from jira cat cells
so we see here at the transcription
start site no nucleosome free region so
this is consistent with these are
developmentally turned off
if we look genome-wide at all the
analysis of genes under active
regulation we can see really quite
remarkable indexing
uh uh from plus and you know to plus and
minus 1.5 kilobase pairs from the
transcription start site
again on chip off chip with without pcr
we see really
fantastic agreement 96 overlapping
nuclear zone position between any pair
regardless of using pcr
on chip or off chip so this is really um
quite quite very good processing
also if we actually look at quantitative
the number of nucleosomes per cell
you can kind of go through the map and
you can see there should be
given the number of base pairs per cell
and how big a nucleosome is roughly
um about one point five times something
seven two fluid zones per cell but again
we hit that right on the uh right on the
head in fact we don't see
the pcr of bias which suggests again we
can go
smaller input in the future
so i want to revisit that chip workflow
what i've talked to you about before is
this
this first step this uh which had never
really been done before but making high
quality
chromatin and microfluidic device and
now move to this immunoprecipitation
step where we're going to be adding in
uh magnetic beads and be able to control
those beats to
pull them out when they bound to their
target
species and so we've been developing for
several years in my lab
a range of different components that can
potentially enable immunocapture and
i'll talk to you first about one of the
ones that
we developed earliest which is what we
call the k channel because if you turn
your turn this device on its side it
looks like a k
right here and in this case we have a
counter flowing
fluid and what we find is that we'll see
the higher pressure in this counter flow
compared to the droplet flow here
uh we have an electric field present
this is an electrode right here
just the saltwater electrode it
destabilizes the interface and we can
inject fluid
into this droplet using the exact same
device
we can reverse the pressure so now we
have a lower pressure from the counter
flow
and now we're pulling off sample so the
same device we can
both add and remove fluid in a
reversible or highly tunable way
at moderate pressures especially if we
turn up the electric field we see no
fluid exchange at all so this
we could turn off the module if we
wanted um
and then finally here i'm showing it
with a oil counter flow where now we're
splitting the droplets in half
so these range of different
functionalities using just this one
um this one k channel uh tool
and you know we like this because we um
though we're chemists
i have taught a lot of chemical
engineers in the past and we like to
think about things sometimes
is unit operations so here we have these
dynamically tunable
unit ops that we can use uh for
microfluidic samples
one other thing i should mention i
didn't mention it earlier is again the
droplet generation rate we typically
work at
is hundreds of hertz so these droplets
are passing by this interface
extremely fast you can see the time on
the videos uh here on the top left
corner
but you know we're making these droplets
very quickly and the reproducibility of
this this process is really
quite phenomenal again kind of
getting back to this idea of unit ops
here's just just an example of how we
can start to think about doing
uh immunoprecipitation by pulling off
magnetic beads and decanting a
supernatant
upstream here we've made a droplets of
that magnetic beads
we didn't flow them across this k
channel that's poised to do droplet
separation
it's a little hard to see with the very
bottom of this channel you can see a few
dark splotches these are beads that are
being pulled down towards a magnet which
is just
out of view and then if we look
downstream at this decanted supernatant
and these drops containing beads we see
uh really uh really nice b meat
enrichment
uh 96 uh beat enrichment and again we're
doing this at
hundreds of droplets per second these
droplets are on the order of about 150
picoliters for reference so actually
very nice size for kind of single cell
analysis
and again just kind of showing this unit
operation here we're splitting a droplet
we're respacing them and here maybe
we're adding in a ribs buffer
the type of you know immunoprecipitation
you might want to do so we can really
put these together
and operate many of them side by side or
any sequence i should say
and do quite complex operations in this
way
now it turns out they're trying to do
still do four buffer exchanges and
buffer washers with very high
uh fidelity it's still difficult with
that module so
uh steve doonan here in my group uh is
now a postdoc of washington university
uh came up with this really clever
approach which he
named very cutely the droplet car wash
and car wash stands for coalesce attract
re-segment washing now this is just
showing showing
how this works schematically here we
have a magnet at the bottom of the
device
we have our droplets containing magnetic
beats they come in
we're applying electric fields across
this interfaces so the electrode we bias
this aqueous flow back here at the input
these are outputs will be coalesce and
once they coalesce
the droplets are free to actually be
pulled
magnetophoretically towards the bottom
of the channel while this fluid is
flowing left to right
so when we do this we actually can get
rid of all of the excess material in the
droplet that's directed just out to
waste
we can then collect just the magnetic
beads and then resuspend them
with an oil flow at the bottom to do
subsequent downstream processing
so this is an example of the car wash
module
in action so here the the droplets some
of them contain beads coming in
and we can see that uh they fly across
down towards the bottom here because
they're magnetically
uh theoretically uh magnetophoretically
pulled to the bottom of the channel
and all the excess material up here just
goes to waste
we can show this even more clearly so
our bead recovery is quite good about 98
but if we spike the incoming droplets
with fluorescein
fluorescent tag and do microscopy on
this we can see that
all the fluorescents really stays up
here at the very top of the channel none
of it makes its way down but very little
of it makes its way down
to where the droplets of the beads are
being re-encapsulated
and here's just a uh cross-sectional
fluorescence image with the one percent
standard here for reference so we're
doing
at least 100 full dilution of the excess
material
or essentially washing the bead by doing
this and it's quite efficient
now the chip process there are multiple
buffers you typically want to use you
want to
use forward buffers typically a low salt
a high salt a lithium chloride in a
what's called a t
buffer so i'm taking advantage of one of
the properties of microfluidics which is
the fluids don't like to mix that well
if they're flowing side by side
um we can actually uh create a
multi-phase flow so in this case
we labeled um our bead sample is
unlabeled as the strep dive in the beads
our low salt buffer has fluorescein our
high salt buffer has no fluorescent
label
and the lithium chlorine buffer has
fluorescent again so these are actually
co-flowing in the bright field image you
can't see anything
but if we wait just a second until it
turns fluorescent again
you'll be able to see and you see the
beads traveling through
here comes the beach they come down and
you see the fluorescence is all confined
up here we have a little bit of leakage
in this this early design
but this is suggesting that we can do
four phase flow
simultaneously and here's a we've got a
fluorescence cross-section so we're
actually pulling through
uh and removing all this excess material
that we this is what we want we aren't
pulling down we want to get rid of an
amino capture experiment
so here we're doing this about 70 hertz
we've slowed it down a little bit
uh then reese's spending droplets into
into the beads into new droplets
so this there's really a lack of a bulk
analog for how you do kind of these
multi-phase
washes simultaneously so this is
something we thought was was pretty um
pretty interesting uh finally
uh or just to kind of put this in
context i've described already
upstream how we can use the m a's device
to digest chromatin we can use this car
wash to
wash the beads um and at present we're
just doing
our dna purification and library
preparation off chip
that's something that we're actively
working on bringing on chip as well and
again there's some precedent for doing
that already
but i just want to share with you one
example uh we don't have quite the
finished story here
but this is one example we're looking at
manual processing and on device
processing
of uh looking at three different genes
that are pulled down through this
h3k4 trimethyls this is histone three
it's a trimethylated lysine four that's
the the
nomenclature for that histone mark and
we can see an enrichment
of this brg one that's that's um uh
specifically associated
with this histone mark and these other
two uh genes
are off target controls we see they're
not enriched and this is a log log plot
so
greater than 2.2 suggesting at least a
10-fold enrichment so
this is really promising when we're
moving this to other marks and you think
that has
um good opportunity so
just as a final thing i wanted to share
with you um
a different tool they'll be developing
um
for droplet operations so in the
micrococcal nucleus device we incubate
it for
a total of 305 seconds or about five
minutes
and while that's that works very well
for microcosm nucleus
there are certainly some assays where we
want to do much longer processing steps
um and uh so you know this might need
tens of minutes for more
incubations and droplets and um space is
timed in a microfluidic device so if you
want more time you need to drop the
travel slower or long or for a longer
distance
and when you do either one of those
processes what you tend to generate is
back pressure in the device and this can
have lots of different problems
and another consequence is that if you
remove back pressure by just making your
channel really big
that then your droplets they start to
diffuse and you get a lot of temporal
heterogeneity because they diffuse
within
laterally or you know from front to back
in time if you will
and you get more temporal heterogeneity
so what we've been interested in
developing a fusion
of on-chip droplet processing and off
chip incubation so we can
take advantage of all the great things
on chip but then actually i'll give you
the word here
it's a little teaser pack the droplets
well if we tightly pack them
we can get really nice bunch of
incubation with a much wider diameter
external tubing that can work for this
um so again i kind of spoiled my my
surprise here
most of the time people use droplet
fluidics with
oil fractions on the over about 50 that
means you've got about
half the volumes oil half the volumes
droplets they're kind of one-to-one
spacing uh periodically and this
releases a significant dispersion of
these droplets
uh so we're interested in removing this
excess oil
after we've done all the processes we
compact them and then put them into this
on-chip incubation device and we just
published this earlier
earlier this year of ming sun a postdoc
in my group
came up with a really clever way to do
this so we've made droplets
uh up here upstream and once you make
droplets they come and they pass
an oil removal module that's what men
get is you actually punched a hole in
the device these are all pdms devices
polymethyl cyloxine and at the bottom of
this
he actually puts a ptfe membrane
and remember that i mentioned that the
oil we use is typically a fluorinated
oil
so that chlorinated oil actually likes
to interact with the ptfe
better than water does so if we apply a
slight negative pressure to this oil
draining module we can effectively pull
the oil out and you can see right here
that
we take this burst droplets at roughly
one to one oil to water
ratio and we can selectively pull out
all the oils we can densely pack these
droplets these are actually
posts of these these white circles in
the incubation channels to give it some
stability
uh so it won't collapse we can really
tightly pack these droplets
and what we find is we pack the droplets
really tightly uh so here's just showing
a device
kind of two devices put together so we
make droplets we pack them
and then we actually have this bridge
incubation tubing
we actually take the chips the the
droplets off
chip in this much wider diameter tubing
before we bring it back in
to another module here that can re-space
the droplets for downstream analysis
and by just using the longer pieces of
tubing or wider diameter tubing
we see that we can get really nice
heterogeneous excuse me homogeneous
incubation
up to 20 minutes but we can actually
there's no reason we shouldn't be able
to go longer
um we're using a fluorescent readout
using an enzymatic substrate a pair that
can turn over and create a
fluorogenic substrate but here we can
get three minute incubation
six ten and twenty we can actually see
an increase in the
um uh the product the enzymatic
fluorescent project
product that's generated uh before it
just starts to be depleted and that's
why it plateaus out so we think this is
kind of a
clever way to um
kind of get us this worldly shift issue
of how you can do a lot of processes
that work well
in a microfluidic device and then you
can get much longer incubation for kind
of all the bulk scale assays that many
people
or analogous the bulk scale assays the
many processes
in screening and things like that once
and then we can put them back into a
device whenever we'd like to control
that incubation timing and do subsequent
processing so we think this is a
kind of a clever little approach to
doing this
uh science1 concludes quickly here um
droplet microfluidic modules can be
created they're tunable
uh provide unit operation capabilities
on you know the hundreds of picoliters
as we typically work on to the nano
liter volume scale
um you can go down to femtometers with
most of these you could go up to
microleaders if you really wanted to but
vandaliters are peaking leaders so it's
kind of the sweet spot for of the
analysis we are interested in
uh in general we think droplet
microfluidicism
presents an attractive approach of
genomic studies because of these dynamic
input capabilities this
lack of nonspecific binding we have very
simple device design so none of our
devices we ever have any active valves
you know we're not opening and closing
channels dynamically we might change the
pressure on a k channel to make it
you know inject rather than remove but
these are uh the grand scheme of things
quite simple microfluidic
devices very passive devices i
demonstrated that we were able to show
efficient chromosome digestion for the
first time in a microfluidic device
that has outstanding performance
relative to bulk methods it allows us to
go to
lower input of requirements you know
potentially down to single cell
processing eventually uh we're still
working on chip we think we're pretty
close to getting it
all working but i showed you that
immunoprecipitation that car wash module
that was really important for a lot of
solid phase extraction approaches that
might
be done in droplet microfluidics and
then finally i showed just a little
teaser there at the end this recent you
know kind of world to chip interface
where we use that ptfe membrane to
allow us to very tightly pack droplets
but yeah keep them stable
and when we tightly pack them we can use
them off chip
incubation for longer periods of time
without getting because once they're
packed the droplets can't diffuse past
one another so
you don't really lose the time indexing
of droplets when you pack them
you just lose a little bit but not very
much um compared to if you have these
just floating in a tube
with 50 oil uh they're present
so with that i'd like to again thank the
organizers for the great opportunity to
speak to you today
i want to point out um ishu uh steve
june and gloria diaz who's uh who've
done most of the work
my lab on this funding sources by
collaborators at mayo clinic
and uh again i'd be um really happy to
have been
invited it's a great pleasure and i'm
happy to take any questions that you
submit i think i'll get them via email
and i will try to get back to you as
soon as possible
i hope you learned something today thank
you very much for your attention